[Music]
here's a PSA to data scientists and
developers do you ever need to get your
code-based analytics into slides then
definitely check out Cordo Cordo is an
open source tool for technical
publishing it lets you combine code
output and narrative say from an
exploratory analysis script or your
jupyter notebook or our markdown Dock
and from that publish all sorts of
output including presentations you can
convert your work into a lovely SL of
slides there's nice support for
PowerPoint as well as Beamer or blatch
slides but let me show you how it works
with the reveal JS example you just add
a little bit of yammo at the top of your
dock to tell Cordo how to publish your
slides and you separate your slides
using markdown headers there's then a
ton of options to customize your slides
and say and show exactly what you want
in part two I'll run through a bunch of
your options slide into your boss's DMS
and quickly run through your analysis
with these sweet Cordo slides and follow
up for more free and open source data
science content